dangerous i just yeah i just put the
[ __ ] i just feel safer
yeah i drive safer yeah but how are you
going to do the podcast you can do zooms
no we've been doing it we have a studio
so we the student is in manhattan the
studio's in brooklyn so my old apartment
we just turned into a studio
so yeah yeah but it's a co-op so i'm a
little i don't know how long we're going
to do it
because co-op the co-op board is like i
the super reason was like hey man uh i
need to check your radiators and i kind
of was like oh [ __ ]
somebody heard chris and stefano yelling
you know i like
men or whatever yeah so yeah we got
so then you you come down you shoot at
once a week we do once a week and do you
knock out
two in the same way we knock out two in
the same day right there and then yeah
it's the hard work of a comedian in 2021
we're done
that's what's going on yeah yeah have
you been touring at all during these
games
and i don't miss it i don't miss it hold
on before you
how long have you been doing stand-up
though long time 15 years whatever yeah
you just did a special uh blowing the
light
yeah produced by andrews yeah it's true
yeah it was on the line
that's right yeah it's still collecting
views yeah it's a great thing about the
internet
youtube it's just up yeah just up that
was that's why specials on tv
it's over because it's like you watch it
and then netflix is still good because
it's up but it
people forget netflix is the internet
it's not tv no it's like
it's the stream it's streaming yeah it's
like it's got to stay up it can't just
air and then be gone
no because you can get new fans yeah
yeah if it's just straight
network tv like uh if you don't if you
don't watch it on friday at
nine it's over you know yeah like uh
they just released my half hour on
comedy central from 2013
and i've just been posting them on my
instagram they used to take them down
but now i think comedy central is like
over
so they're not they used to just they
had like uh some sort of algorithm that
found
yes and took it down but now they're
leaving up so i'm cutting it up and
putting it up
right cool with it are they not cut are
they cutting it up on their instagram
too no they put the whole thing up on
youtube but then i was like let me try
because i kept trying to put them up
yeah
and then they would take them down so i
put it up maybe they're going to take
them down now but it was like
they're putting them up on instagram i
should keep my mouth shut
they're probably watching this going
like how is this how can we turn comedy
central to this now
pretty soon you can say welcome to
comedy central and then it's just going
to be [ __ ] a podcast
yeah yeah comedy central is under a
different management now so they're
probably like man if he posts what are
we going to do with this yeah
[ __ ] material i guess they don't care
anymore i mean why would they it's like
this helps
it's a clip that would send people to go
watch the whole special see i
i think there's still a huge uh
opportunity for a comedy central like
you look at their like digital platform
like their their
social media and their especially
youtube's huge yeah
it's like [ __ ] your your network tv yeah
that's whatever yeah but if digital like
putting special on deal like norman i
think
or no no no did it yeah there's been a
few people that do it there man yeah and
sam's got
it got millions of views
like how the [ __ ] does that happen it's
just the era where
uh yeah i don't know if they're looking
for the most experienced comics anymore
they're kind of looking for you gotta
have a story yeah i've got some sort of
story yeah
yeah so i gotta start pushing my story
more
if i wanted to get your origin story
just is it a cool story though you got
to be a victim man it's like i got i've
been
shot which is you know you've been shot
i've been shot so yeah i never talk
about that
how are you i was a social worker for
five years i help people
and who shot you yeah um it was an
attempted robbery
but i got shot point black grains yeah
point blank range i got shots see
melanie
where is that he was like that's when
you were a bodyguard
they always come back see what i'm
saying
he told me
yellow stuff
i do love when rogan posts those fake
karate videos that [ __ ] is always
hilarious when he does that guy's going
like that the other guy's like
and then you see a real fight ufc it's
like mostly wrestling and like yeah
that's not how it goes
like so you just got shot you were uh
yeah so i was like
when i first started how long was this
this was 2001 um
2001. so i first i had like that's when
i started new york was crazy
because new york was fine which was good
new york had started
new york started to change like in the
mid uh 90s the club that i worked at was
[ __ ] wild
it was like the night was just a wild
night um
it was you can actually there's a story
the what something else that happened at
that club was there was like this
really famous director who was coming up
and uh he was like walking home one
night
and somebody got shot in their car
at that club at that party that night
and he decided to drive and then he died
while he was driving
and he just hit that guy walking that
was the end of his life
soho new york the club is called envy
dude your origin story is pretty cool i
would keep this yeah i got to start
pushing that yeah dude so it was gang
related
you know yeah for them it was no not for
me that was how he knew he started he
started doing some time
or you want the real score yeah i used
to be like you know
at the time i was like you know i was
helicoptering over darfur
and saving children you know and you
take some fire but for the kids you know
it wasn't i didn't even feel it
because what i was doing was such a
humanitarian
you know i don't know if it was the
adrenaline or my heart i think part of
it was my heart for the kids
i was able to get six kids out they have
both their limbs
six kids i was holding three in each arm
and you know they were easier to hold
because they didn't have all their arms
they have all that that's really mean
i'm sorry but you know they were
mining for diamonds and i was able to
save it i took one bullet
actually it's too few
yeah it wasn't sexy at all like that i
my my friend hurt like a
mother burns it doesn't hurt the
adrenaline takes care of you man
it's wild but the having the moment
where you think you're gonna die
is uh is great it's great
it's great great how did you know i was
so happy
i was like i'm never going to see anyone
again i'm going to die
it's a great moment i've been waiting
how did you know that's why the last
word
good
right before that big guy started raping
your [ __ ] that's great
great moment right he ripped it right
yes this is great it's a great sorry
it's hilarious um he shot me it was a
point it was point blank range so i was
with my uh
my friend who was a party promoter he
carried a lot of cash with him out of
the party he was stupid yeah
so um he would have a uh bouncer
bodyguard walk with him
to the car so the guy walked us to the
car i remember put a box of flyers in
the
uh you know he's a club promoter in the
backseat and then
uh he walked away went around the corner
and then as i was getting in the
passenger
side seat i saw the guy coming he had a
mask on gloves and a gun and i was like
[ __ ] i made a decision to try to get
in the car and tell him to drive
but the kid kind of sped up and then he
kind of fell into the car
in the passenger seat and then like i
saw the gun and i just grabbed his arm
and like pushed it down and he fired and
i got hit right here in the inside leg
like that's a bad spot to get hit yeah
but thank god my piece is not that big
so it's just
one time i was happy to have a tiny
piece
he's lucky man yeah lucky dude your
virgin store is good
yeah i gotta yeah i gotta go into
meetings start with that yeah
start with the show yeah how about that
when i get off stage at the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this run a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son